Hey guys, we are back
And I'm super excited because today's the day we get to rip open the silicone molds and see how our
pokeballs turned out.
These have been sitting out for about a day and a half now and they still look really shiny.
It almost looks like you could touch it and get sticky fingers. You can even see bubbles forming on the top here
However, this silicone has fully cured and should be completely rubber.
Ooh, check this out.
So this is our leftover silicone, and you can see it
just peels right out of the bowl and leaves the bowl almost as clean as when we started. It's almost like a rubbery skin.
Super Stretchy.
Look at that. (pop)
Well as cool as this is, this is garbage and we can throw that away.
The time has come to extract our pokéballs
and I don't think we're going to be able to get these silicone chunks straight up and out. They created a vacuum seal and that's
gonna be nearly impossible.
Now to clean up these edges we can just take an exacto knife and just kind of carve around to clean everything up a little bit.
Obviously, we're not going to be able to pull this thing off the bottom. So we're just going to take this and pull them off the base plate
Here we go. The hot glue served its purpose so we can peel that away
Oh man the friction. That's really tough. You know might be best if I just cut this thing with a hacksaw.
There we go!
With your acrylic cut we can just split it open,
set it off to the side and there is a rubber plug.
So there we go, you can see we've got a solid chunk of silicone now
The acrylic is fully removed and on the bottom all we have is this layer of hot glue and then our pokeballs inside
so let's use something like an exacto knife to slowly carve away the silicone to see if we can extract the pokeball
And salvage ourselves a silicone mold!
And we gotta make sure we don't scratch up the actual pokeball itself. It doesn't belong to me. (laughs)
Making some good progress here
There we go. That makes me wonder...
Oh yeah, so looking inside here it looks like we did get some little air bubbles along the ridges,
which is a little bit too bad, but it's definitely something we can work with.
All right down the last piece here...
Yeah!
Alright! One side has released. We can get the rest of the ball out
just by simply peeling the silicon away and gently prying the ball back.
We had a little silicone that went underneath that hot glue.
And there it's released, in almost as good condition as it went in! There is a chance that even with these imperfections
we will still be able to cast it and it will come out fairly clean
So I'm just gonna stop there. We're going to call it good and theoretically we should be able to put this thing back together.
And now we've got a little hole where we can pour in anything that we want and cast
ourselves our own little pokeball. I like having the rocks in there because it adds weight,
and I can probably just set this on my bookshelf and leave it kind of as a centerpiece. That's really cool.
Now, we've got these two halves and when we press them together
It creates a little opening in the top where we can pour in anything that we want and make ourselves our own little pokeball
So this is pretty much gonna be the same deal as the last one, but I gotta be a little more delicate
There we go, I can feel that letting go now
and boom.
There's our ball!
Salvaged!
Now this is kind of cool. Look down inside here and inside the mold you can actually see all the battle wounds the battle
bruised pokeball wounds which is going to translate into our castings when we make them. Just thought that looked kinda cool.
There we have it! Mold number two good to go!
You see the thing causing this problem was the silicon is hanging up in these little gaps here
Those aren't completely airtight
Unfortunately.
It still work?
Still works!
Look at the way the silicone actually seeped inside the pokeball and collected all these rocks.
Silicone has this amazing way of creeping into every place that is not completely airtight.
The nice thing is that it cleans up very easily and
doesn't make that big of a mess. The electrical cords actually got sucked right into the silicone,
and now they are rubberized! (laughs)
For free!
Got almost everything out now
So this is pretty cool guys. Now that got ourselves a pokeball mold what you want to see me do with it?
I had one idea I thought might be fun
So I went down to the store and picked up a couple of colored candles so all that's left to do now is take this
wax and throw it in a pot so we can melt it down, pour it into these molds and then let it sit overnight
So tomorrow we can open these things up and see what kind of results
they actually produce and if it actually works out
I've got an idea for a future project that might be a lot of fun.
So there you have it guys we successfully extracted our pokéballs from the silicon and now we've got a couple of molds filled with wax
You'll find out in another video exactly how they turn out
And Devon you'll be happy to know that I got your ball back out scratch free, it's coming back your way. And to everyone else,
thanks so much for joining me for this experiment. I'll be looking for in the next video. Talk to you then.
You got the chocolate bar out and the silicone cleaned up, and now we've got a custom silicone mold for making snicker bars
mmm.